you can get anything you want in life if
you can get other people to get it for
you which makes persuasion among the
highest leveraged skills in the world
tons of research has been done on how to
become more persuasive and I have to
give my nod to Robert Kiel do you need
to go who made most research accessible
to the masses in his book influence what
I want to do is show you the most
effective ways I applied his methods in
my own business that now do over 200
million dollars a year in combined
revenue tool number one is reciprocity I
try to get in contact with Arnold
Schwarzenegger when I was running
gymwatch I thought it would make a lot
of sense I wanted him to endorse my book
that was like my whole goal turns out
nothing worked it also turns out Arnold
doesn't really care but in order to get
his attention what Layla and I did was
he donated a million dollars to his
charity and then we ended up sitting
down with Arnold multiple times when you
show kindness and generosity towards
others they're more likely to return the
favor and like you as a result the gift
you have to do is proportional to the
person you're trying to give to so for
example if you pay for your friend's
lunch that person now feels obligated to
return the favor they're like hey I'll
get the next one right and it's the same
reason that outside of a retail store as
soon as you you come in they offer you
cold water it's not because they're nice
people it's because they know that
you'll feel indebted to them and be more
likely to a stay longer be listening to
them and see ultimately buy imagine how
much it costs a store owner to give
everybody who walks in the door a water
I don't know five dollars a day and if
they get one person to buy extra a week
off of that which they probably get a
lot more is that worth the investment
it's probably the highest return on
investment thing in his entire business
now keyaldine gives a really beautiful
example of how to leverage this in
business he shows an example for a
waiter so if a waiter puts a mint on the
bill they get three percent more tips
right people get something and they're
more likely to tip them a little bit
more the waiter gives the person two
minutes all of a sudden the tips
increase by 14 and the third way they
did the waiter example was that the
person put a mint down walked away turn
around and put another mint on the table
and that created a 23 increase in tips
it's worth paying five dollars a month
for a big bag of mints just to make sure
you get paid but the thing is is that in
business there are tons of these five
dollar mint bags that are laying around
you can immediately implemented your own
business years ago I actually had this
done to me and I saw the effect and it
was wild all right so there was this guy
that I thought was a complete weirdo
whenever I saw him he would try and ask
me like 100 questions so he was local to
where I was he was in like some
entrepreneur networks and he would just
like try and Corner me and I was like
dude just get away from me eventually I
had to confront and be like stop talking
to me like go away and so what happened
is he was so ashamed of the whole
experience whatever he started sending
me gifts every single month so I'm
talking about like 500 000 gifts every
month like Cutco knives and like
clothing which is kind of weird but it
was expensively lemon stuff anyways for
nine months you see so many birthday
cakes that were custom made and ice
cream like was wild after a while I just
started feeling bad because he just kept
sending them and saying like so sorry I
hope everything's awesome blah blah blah
and I was like you know what maybe I
just saw him the wrong way and I was
just like got him off on the wrong foot
even though I knew what he was doing it
still worked and I ended up going out to
meet him again turns out still a weirdo
and so that's to show you how powerful
this stuff is you can just start by
giving people free gum when you're in
class which is the first time I learned
it when I was in Middle School porn is
mean to me when I gave them gum earlier
that day and so this tiny little thing
that cost me almost nothing that made my
life in middle school a little bit
easier tool number two is consistency we
judge people based on their actions all
right consistency can be used in
Persuasion by asking someone to publicly
commit to an idea or action a public key
can be just in front of you but it can
also be widely to the world if I said
hey are you the type of person who like
takes action and is willing to invest in
themselves if someone says yes then
later on if I say hey since you're the
type of person who's really willing to
take action and really likes to invest
in themselves and I think this would be
perfect for you boom and then I can make
the ass because I just reminded them
twice of the commitments they made
earlier and I'm asking them to be
consistent with those later during the
close so there's a famous research study
they did where they asked people in a
neighborhood to put up a little sign
that said please Drive slowly when they
ask people to put a massive sign on
their front yard that said please Drive
slowly most people didn't comply with
that request but when they asked people
to put a tiny little sign in their
window the size of a note card that said
please Drive slowly and then two weeks
later they sent them a letter that said
hey since you're a type of person who's
so pro-safety for the neighborhood but
would you be willing to put a much
bigger sign to save more lives guess
what way more people said yes after
saying the first yes because they
voluntarily identified as a certain type
of person and the researchers got them
to remain consistent with the commitment
that they had made and so if you want to
get the big yes sometimes you get the
small yes first this is why lead magnets
and front-end offers tend to work well
to get people to ultimately buy a much
bigger thing later tool number three is
social proof people look to other people
for cues about how to behave or what to
believe and this is how we learn to be
human right when we're little kids we
just look at other people we say oh do
what they do because that's what humans
do and then you start to become a human
if you see something on Amazon it has
five thousand five star reviews you're
way more likely to buy it Amazon does
this stuff because it knows it gets
people to take action and so if you've
ever heard a laugh track on a show where
it's like hahaha in the background
people then laugh more than if there is
no laugh track which is wild we are so
conditioned to behave in accordance with
how everyone else does that that laugh
track persuades US gets us to do
something they want us to do which is LA
F better than anything else and so
here's how I use it in my own businesses
I printed out every single five star
review I got online if you have a brick
and mortar location this is where it
kills is that you look at all your Yelp
reviews and you screenshot every single
one of them so I screenshotted all of
them and I framed every one of them so
that floor to ceiling my Lobby was five
star reviews and then the other half was
before and after pictures because
imagine a world where someone says like
hey Alex I don't think you can help me
lose weight and I would just like look
around the room be like really
and then I would say how much proof
would you need to believe and at what
point is your requirement for proof more
and reasonable than the amount of proof
I have and that crushes their belief of
whether or not they could do it or at
least that I was good enough to do it
tool number four liking or what people
would like to call Rapport people like
people who like them or they perceive as
friends and the more you like someone
the more likely they are to say yes to
you and so the liking principle states
that people are more likely to be
persuaded by those that they like and
want to be like and that's the second
part is important and they even did a
research study to test this they told
people that they paid strangers to
compliment them they then got
complimented by a stranger who they knew
were getting paid to compliment them and
guess what they still like them more
than strangers they didn't and so even
if you know what someone's doing it
still works and they also found out that
there's actually no cap to how much
flattery someone will take provided it's
genuine and here's how I try to use this
in Persuasion so I always use the ACA
framework acknowledge what they say
compliment what they did about what they
said and then ask another question you
can get basically anybody to like you in
a sales conversation or an associate
situation acknowledge what they just
said because it shows that you're
listening and paying attention to them
because the thing that people like more
than anything that they pay people
hundreds of dollars an hour to is just
to listen to them talk C you compliment
them on what they just said and how it
ties to them being a great person in
some positive attribute and then you ask
them the next question to move them down
the conversation and so the way that I
actually was able to keep my spirits
High because if you are ever front
facing in a role whether it's customer
service or at sales or anything you get
tired and so what I did was that I
actually bought a mini trampoline and I
put it next to my desk and so I would
meet with people and I I was doing 20
plus consults a day in person and I
would be bouncing on this trampoline and
they would look at me like a psychopath
people would close more because like
this guy's such a goof you cannot be in
a bad mood and on a trampoline and when
I didn't have the trampoline before that
I actually used to do a cartwheel every
single time before I shook someone's
hand when they walk in my gym so imagine
you walk in the gym some guy to the car
wheel and it's like hey welcome to
United Fitness nice to meet you my name
is Alex you would crack up be like who
is this guy but you know what you did
after that you give me money because you
liked me automatically even if someone
was a sourpuss I could still turn the
mood around because what they ultimately
wanted to buy was the feeling that I was
giving them during the conversation
persuasion tool number five is Authority
think about a man who can tell the
president of the United States to drop
his trousers and stick his finger up his
ass well Proctologist can do that
whenever they want because they're a
doctor and in the doctor's office they
are the authority if Warren Buffett
gives you investment advice you can move
on it faster because you just trust that
he's right even if his advice is the
same as a high school teacher the reason
it's so powerful is not because what an
authority says is actually more
persuasive in terms of the actual words
they say but because people put up fewer
filters and accept more things as truth
which means it has more persuasive
ability independent of the message as
soon as you find a trusted Source what
do you do you just listen to it right
which is why mentors are so valuable
because it actually decreases our speed
to decision making and getting action
done which is why we seek out mentors to
begin with which is maybe why you watch
stuff on YouTube what do you have to do
to do this you show diplomas credentials
Awards Etc and your track record which
is if you followed my Channel at all all
I talk about is building your life
resume and having a track record to
stand on rather than puffing your chest
and having lots of Charisma instead just
saying you can believe me because of
what I've done not what I'm telling you
I'm going to do but on top of that if
you want to add third party
accreditation I printed out
certifications for myself and every one
of my trainers because people would come
and be like well are your trainer
certified I would say like one which
ones do you want they would never have
any idea and two I would say all of my
trainers are double or triple certified
mind you certifications are not
accredited in the United States meaning
I could have 10 certifications that I
certified them myself
no one knows I did pay for my trainers
to get certified through actual ones but
I also internally certified them so they
had more Authority persuasive tool
number six scarcity and urgency urgency
is a function of time so promotion ends
tomorrow scarcity is a function of units
I only have a hundred of them left
people value what is scarce the reason
gold is inherently valuable versus a
rock is that there's just less of it the
reason De Beers has become this diamond
conglomerate even though rubies and
sapphires are actually rarer than
diamonds is they own all the diamonds
they keep them in vaults just so that
they can keep the scarcity high enough
on the diamonds they fesh a premium
price and so the way that you implement
this in Persuasion is that you use
limits limited time limit Supply one
time offers to create the perception of
scarcity the other way to doing is
talking lost language so instead of like
don't you want to get it's you don't
want to miss out on different way of
framing the same concept people have
more loss aversion than they have desire
to gain so if you've seen Chanel or
Gucci or Prada or whatever they actually
don't tell the stories how much of any
item they'll send they'll have a new
spring line and they'll send one or two
or three purses and they won't tell the
store how many they're going to send in
a real way the sales people have the
same concept of urgency they probably
figured it out at corporate that even if
they said hey say that we don't have
that many purses the sales people like
actually we got more in the back and so
they just actually control the whole
thing centrally they only send them and
they're like I don't know when I'm gonna
get the next one in or if I'm going to
get another one in at all but then they
took it even further and during covet if
you saw it there were lines out the door
because there's like one person and one
person out you know what stores kept
that while everyone else Let It Go the
fancy stores because they want to hold a
scarce resource they want to show that
there's tons of demand that's a little
bit of social proof you have to be
special it's exclusive in order to get
in the key to doing this is not being
fake I don't know how to say this to you
differently besides trust me if you
actually put true scarcity on something
you will sell more so if you can handle
20 people a week in your business or you
have X amount of product tell people
your limits the reason Amazon still says
23 left in stock is because they know
that more people will buy it if they see
that there's limits so if I said hey I
continue a thousand customers smart you
probably couldn't take them so just be
explicit about how many you have left
and you'll actually sell more